it's the entertainment is about ready to
begin first talk of the final session of
the day is by yo wanna walk lainnya
thank you so before I begin I would like
to thank the organizers so first of all
I would like to thank the organizers of
the program logical structures in
computation so I was given the
opportunity to spend the whole semester
here and it's absolutely great and of
course i would like to also thank the
organizers of this workshop I'm very
happy to give it here today so i will be
talking about definable constraint
satisfaction problems so well you all
know what constraint satisfaction
problems are we already heard quite a
lot about them today there is also the
notion of the high nobility in the title
of my talk and this is the final bility
in the sense that was defined by McCoy
during his talk on Monday so briefly
what my talk will be about this
constraint satisfaction problems in the
framework of definable sets with atoms
and the results that I will present
today our joint work with better clean
at a cop change keys for the class oda
and tremont around check ok so let me
begin with reminding you the notion of
atoms so in McCoy stock we had a choice
we could actually decide for atoms to be
any structure so in my talk I decided to
take the simplest possible option so I
will just assume that atoms are elements
of some countably infinite set so I just
assume that atoms have knows no other
structure than equality so this is well
natural numbers with the quality well
from Big O I stock ok so once we know
what atoms are let me give you me let me
give you an example of an instance of
the kind of problems that we want to
consider so let's think about an
infinite and directed graph G so this
graph G has infinitely many vertices the
vertices are pairs of distinct atoms
so whoops a b.a.d etc infinitely many
vertices of this form and we put an edge
between two different vertices a B and
bc whenever we see a pattern like this
so for every three distinct atoms a B
and C we put an edge between the
vertices a B and bc so here you have a
picture of some finite sub graph of the
infinite graph G and the question we are
interested in well in this case is
whether this graph is three colorable so
you can think about this as an instance
of three color ability the only
difference comparing to what we heard
before is that the instance is infinite
so well the first thing is that it's
even not sure if we can actually decide
such problem for infinite instances but
actually well the answer for this
particular question is no because this
sub graph of the infinite grab G is not
recoverable ok so well let me briefly
remind you a notion about the definition
of the constraint satisfaction problem
so I mainly do it because I want to so
well as liebert told you that there are
well and as you know there are many
possible formal like you can formalize
constraint satisfaction problems in many
different ways so i will in my i assume
that this is the problem for given a
finite structure on input decide whether
there is a homomorphism from the finite
structure I to define its structure T so
this is the classical version of the
constraint satisfaction problem we have
a fixed finite template so a fixed
finite relational structure we are given
a final structure on an input and we
want to decide whether there is a
homomorphism and well we've already seen
quite a few examples of this problem so
well if the structure t is this
structure then this then we can
formalize three-color ability if the
structure t is the structure with two
elements and well it's actually enough
to have those two relations that we can
formalize solving linear equations
that too well but as I told you I will
like in my talk I will be interested in
definable structures so I will consider
a variant of a constraint satisfaction
problems where structures instead of
being finite can be definable so well
you know the different well those of you
who attended Miko a stock on Monday
already know the definition of a
definable set so define a definable
structure is just a structure whose
domain and all relations are definable
sets with atoms but to make it a bit
easier during this talk I will assume
that the domain of a definable structure
is just a set of tuples of atoms and
relations are defined by first order
formula over well that use only equality
so for example the graph that we
considered at the very beginning is a
definable structure because the because
its domain is just well sets of pairs of
distinct atoms well you see them of
three of them here and the edge relation
is defined using this first order of
this very easy first order formula
well equivalently we can consider we can
talk about structures that are fo
interpretable in the stress in the
natural numbers of equality so I guess
most of you are familiar with the notion
of fo interpretability from model theory
so we've already seen one example of
this so what what do we modify in the
definition of of the constraint
satisfaction problem so the first
modification that I want to consider is
instead of considering final structures
we consider definable structures as an
input so the template the fixed
structure is still a finite structure
the only difference that I make is that
instead of considering finite structures
and it as an input and take definable
structures okay so another yes yes okay
so yeah so we've already seen one
example of this kind of problem so three
color ability of definable graph perhaps
he'll here is another example so so
definable system solving definable
systems of linear equations so I don't
formalize it I don't formalize this as a
relational structure but I guess you can
all see that we can do it so the
template is this finite relational
structures and well an example of an
instance is this infinite set infinite
system of linear equations so the
variables are ordered pairs of distinct
atoms so once more we have infinitely
many variables and we have two types of
equations for every pair of these things
Adams a and B we have an equation a B+
be a equals one and for every triple of
the sink Adams a B and C we have an
equation of the type a BBC a B plus BC
plus CA equals zero so infinitely many
equations of this form and infinitely
many equations of this form well and the
question is whether this system have a
solution so this is a definable instance
over this template and actually once
more this system does not have a soul
because this finite sub system of the
whole infinite system already does not
have a solution Oh actually I don't know
No okay so yeah so I as I mentioned at
the very beginning it's not actually
it's not clear whether such problems are
decidable but well the first theorem
that I want to talk about today is the
theorem that says that actually well for
every finite template t the definable
constraint satisfaction problem of the
over this template is it is a decidable
problem and actually well this theorem
is in a sense even stronger because we
can we can be given on the input a
definable structure I and the final
structure tea and we can decide whether
there exists a homomorphism from I to t
so well how do we do it well obvious
answer we have to look for symmetric
homomorphisms so the lemma which
actually solves the problem says that
for definable structure I and the final
structure t the following conditions are
equivalent we have a homomorphism if and
only if we have a common morphism which
is constant on orbitz under the monotone
permutations of atoms so let me explain
to you what it means on an example well
our running example so the graph that we
so this is just the finite sub graph of
the graph that they defined at the very
beginning so how can we decide whether
this graph is three colorable using the
lemma so what we do is we fix some
linear order on atoms an order that is
isomorphic to the order of rationals
well on the atoms that are mentioned on
this picture this can be well for
example a smaller than be smaller than
see smaller than be smaller than e this
is just like to make it easy well it
will be anything else so what happens if
if we fix this order well before we have
the order the vertices are kind of the
same so well formally there is
one orbit of the vertices under the
action of permutations of atoms but once
we fix the order we get two kinds of
vertices so we can we have the vertices
that are marked in black so those are
the vertices where the first coordinate
is smaller than the second one and we
have those vertices that are marked in
grey so those are those vertices where
the first coordinate is bigger than this
the second one so formally this means
that we have two orbits under the
monotone permutations of atoms and for
actually for every definable instance
it's easy to see that you get finally
many orbits under the monotone
permutations of atoms and now our lemma
says that if this graph is three
colorable then there exists a
three-color ability that assigns the
same color to all vertices marked in
black and the same color to all vertices
market in grey and well even from this
finite sub graph we already see that
this is impossible ok so well so once
you see this you can ask yourself ok but
why do you bother to introduce the order
you already have an action of a group
you already have finitely many orbits
like you can just consider all
permutations so why do you need to
introduce the order so it's easy to see
that considering the action of the all
of all permutations of atoms is not
enough so let's consider this very well
kind of trivial sis infinite systems
system of linear equations so we have
just so once more we have infinitely
many variables pairs of distinct atoms
and we have just one type of of
equations a B+ be a equals 1 so this
system is obviously solvable we just
assign we just pick one of those and
assign one to this to this one and 0 to
this one and we do the same for every
pair of atoms but if we think about all
permutations of atoms then we have just
one orbit of variables so of course
there does not exist a solution which is
constant on this single on this
single orbit once we introduce the order
we get two orbits and of course well if
we assign just one to this orbit and
zero to the other orbit then we get a
solution so well it's not enough to
consider orbit under all permutations of
items and actually the deeper reason is
that the like we obtain this result
using well I either ramsay ramsey
theorem or some results from topological
dynamics which talk about well ramsey
structures so and this structure is not
Ramsay ok so once we got the
decidability we were interested in
complexity and actually already from the
construction that from this lemma and
from the from the from the from how the
decidability results result goes we can
see that the complexity of this problem
is that most exponentially bigger so the
complexity of the definable constraint
satisfaction problem over finite
template is that most exponentially
bigger than the complexity of the
corresponding constraint satisfaction
problem for the finite template it turns
out that actually this can be made this
connection can be made tight so if the
constraint if we have some template T
and the concentrate so then the
constraint satisfaction and the
constraint satisfaction problem the
classical one over this template is see
complete for some complexity class c
then the definable constraint
satisfaction problem over the same
template is is a XC complete where well
I don't want to define formally what is
the X what does the class x.x see but
well this table gives you an intuition
what what it is and for example yes
what's more chilling to say
so what all types of classes c-could you
consider so so the soda mmm the
reduction here are logarithmic so you
cannot get below and well and of course
you don't need to get above at P so okay
so and an example well we know that
three color ability of five and graph is
np-complete which means that the three
color ability of the final definable
graph is next complete okay so let me
give back get back to the definition of
our blog problem so this is the problem
that we considered so find a template
definable structure well we understand
we understood this problem so well what
is the next step well we got interested
in the question what happens if the
template itself is a definable structure
the attraction of CSP class cases is
that so many problems can model the
series when you can't really find a BCS
people they fix template well well
that's some natural computation problems
that so and i would say that there is
like there is no natural computational
problems i think that that what so well
on one hand the motivation is that it
seems to be at like from the purely
theoretical point of view it seems to be
a natural like natural question to ask
and on the other hand if you if you want
to so so this kind of infinite symmetric
instances were considered before and the
motivation I'm sorry I don't remember
the names and the motivation was that
sometimes you might have an instance
which is well big enough so that like on
one hand very big and on the other hand
very symmetric and then it's reasonable
to assume that it's actually an infinite
symmetric symmetric instance
but but you're right it's it does not
have such well such well motivations
practical motivations
okay so okay so now our question is what
happens if both the template and the
instance are definable structures and it
turns out that this problem is also
decidable and well as before it's even
decidable given to definable structures
int whether there exists a homomorphism
from I to T and this result we obtain by
reducing it to the previous case so it
turns out that for any definable
structure T the problem the definable
constraint satisfaction problem over the
template team is polynomial time
reducible to a constraint set aside to a
definable constraint satisfaction
problem over some finite structure t t
prime which is computable from t so well
this solved this problem and actually
this construction is a generalization of
of a result of bodie risky and Antoine
is well from the actually from the same
paper that he was talking about one of
the papers he was talking about today so
this reduction it's also not very
difficult to see that this reduction
also gives us some results concerning
complexity so well one of the thing that
is not difficult to observe is that from
this lemma it follows that the
complexity of the problem the definable
constraint satisfaction problem over
definable structures is at most next
time well you can actually have like
well you can you can say more about
complexity so we don't have such a nice
result as we have for finite templates
but well it's it's like from this it
follows like you can say more about
complexity okay so well let's go back to
this to this definition so well we
changed finite to definable here we
changed final to definable here so well
what else can we make definable so well
so it's so the only thing that remains
fine it on this on this picture is the
number of relations so it well if you
already have definable templates then
maybe you want to have also a definable
signature this can allow you for example
to have a predicate for every atom which
could correspond to like adding
constants in the classical CSP so well
we also understood quite well this case
but unfortunately it turns out that okay
so this is our our definable signature
now so unfortunately it turns out that
this general this this variant of
constraint satisfaction problem is not
as well behaved so there exists a
definable structure T of course over a
definable signature such that the
problem becomes undecidable but on the
other hand there are many cases where
this problem is still decidable in
particular if every relation so we can
have infinitely many relation but if
every relation itself contains only
finitely many tuples then the problem is
still decidable and this can be solved
very similarly to the case when the
template is a fine structure ok so I'm
very close to a conclusion so let me
finish with a few remarks so first of
all I showed you the side I showed you
some results for structures that I
definable over atoms which are well
let's say natural numbers with the
quality so well those results holds in
much more much bigger generality so well
we didn't actually think about the
complexity but the decidability results
well you have to make some model
theoretic assumptions about the
structure of atoms well many of those
model theoretical notions we already
heard today but I don't want to go into
details but well the decidability holds
also for atoms that are that are ordered
which well from the result that you have
further proof from the proof that you
have seen it's pretty obvious but also
for atoms that are
that are that are definable over a
random graph and other structures okay
what kind of order it is yes yes it yes
it has to be the order like this
structure has to be isomorphic to
rational number with order okay so the
second point that I want to make at the
end is that well I i considered
basically all possible variants of
taking finite and putting instead
definable except for this one so we keep
the input to be a final structure and
consider a definable template so this is
actually so this problem is has actually
been studied for a much longer time and
well Antoine told us quite a lot about
this today so it was mostly studied for
structures letter read acts well here in
this if we if we consider a fixed
definable template this basically means
that we consider structures that are fo
interpretable with for example natural
numbers of the quality so well standing
this class of problems in general seems
to well they will probably be some
problems but there are well there are
some result there are already some
results about about well structures for
example definable over natural numbers
with a quality and well yeah so what did
ski and his co-authors are working on
this so well and of course and
understanding this those problems for
for well arbitrary definable templates
well over some reasonable structure
seems to be a like I guess for me most
interesting problem in this in this
class of problems okay and finally well
I think that this day is kind of a
homomorphism isomorphism day so so let
me mention a last last thing which is an
open problem so well I I talked a lot
about homomorphisms differen
versions and most of them decidable but
there is a natural problem well
isomorphism problem given to definable
structures a and B say / natural numbers
of equality so well in the model
theoretic language is just two
structures that are fo interpretable
over natural numbers with a quality can
we decide whether those structures are
isomorphic so this is an open problem I
really have no idea how to solve it so
it seems that all the techniques that we
used to deal with how morphisms do not
work here so well if you have any ideas
or if you like let me know thank you we
definitely have time for questions yes
maybe I didn't say I mean one way to you
this if you have to give it answer to
motivation is that I mean many of your
results show that if you pass from
finite to orbit fyodor definable
whatever just questions are sings well
behaved and for CSP you show in many
cases are indeed well behaved in the
sense that these remains decidable and
of course CSP can just be understood as
a interesting fragment of NPR of
existential second-order logic where
many things work that do not work in the
general setting and so when I asked this
question in general so for for what
parts of existence of second-order logic
remains things reasonably well behaved
when you go from finite to to orbit
finite or two definable and do you know
other
stop sympathetic mm-hmm well so well
that's wrong can also be seen in that
context right obviously it's a Tempe
problem where we don't know whether S&P
and you lift it to the definable setting
what about you but we don't know if it's
well behavior and yeah I don't know
Sally results by feather and body but
anyway you would increase the hmmm S&P
within a quality so monotone East you
hit all of India mm-hmm so what
sometimes we give everything there now
it's question was this when I screw it I
love it well but like we obviously we
well we already get out of NP in many
cases so well the like the weld the
notion of being well-behaved has to be
like well it's it becomes so yeah so the
question is I think that the the
question the first question will be what
would we want what would we mean by
well-behaved here so I'm for NP what the
excess 10 second or logically I don't
pee before we decided by comet on there
is color but interpret second-order
logic well we best approach is to
interpret the second order variables and
also arranging only over orbit finite
sets if even so an orbit finite set can
have infinitely many orbit finite
subsets in it so you still have enough
stuff there to really worry about
are there any more questions then thank
you